[Music]
the original doom saga takes place over
20,000 years in our future earth is only
mentioned a handful of times according
to the appendix to religion of doom the
Commission of ecumenical translators
commute on what is referred to as Old
Earth which was considered a neutral
territory this was shortly after the but
Larry in Jihad in dune Messiah the face
dancer sky tell wonders about something
called the Golden Age of earth did fatik
for example know whence came his measure
for this weight of spice did he ever
think to himself that one and a half
comte are once limited a camel load not
likely Farrukh might never even have
heard of a camel or of the Golden Age of
Earth the Golden Age of Earth is
mentioned again by poll how much history
do you know Paul mused aloud studying
the shadowy figure beside him milord I
can name every world our people touched
in their migrations I know the reaches
of Imperial the Golden Age of Earth have
you ever studied that earth golden age
still gar was irritated and puzzled why
would Paul wish to discuss myths from
the dawn of time sky tell assumed that
Farrukh had likely never heard of earth
and still bar reacted as they all spoke
of some legend when he mentioned earth
in Children of Dune Leto ii recalls
earth in his genetic memory it gave him
a sense of timeless buoyancy to know
that few in his universe would recall
Chaucer or know any London except the
village on Ganser eaned
st. Thomas was preserved in the orange
Catholic Bible and the azure book but
Canterbury was gone from the memories of
men as was the planet which had known it
Leto minjun's that Canterbury was gone
from the memories of men just as the
planet it was from for some reason the
earth seems to be almost entirely
forgotten in the dew
universe and it's not exactly clear why
but is it still around this question
actually is answered in the original
dune saga in god emperor of doom Leto
recalls memories of Earth
this morning I was born in a yurt at the
edge of a horse plane in a land of a
planet which no longer exists
tomorrow I will be born somewhere else
in another place I have not yet chosen
this morning though ah this life when my
eyes had learned to focus I looked out
at sunshine on trampled grass and saw
vigorous people going about the sweet
activities of their lives
where oh where has all of that vigour
gone and in Chapter house of dune the
Bene Jesuit Reverend Mother Oh trade
refers to Old Earth as gone as they
continued their walk in the aromatic
hollow o draids voice once more became
pensive each planet has its own
character where we draw patterns of Old
Earth sometimes it's only a faint sketch
but here we have succeeded she knelt and
pulled a twig from an acid green plant
crushing it in her fingers she held it
to his nose
sage she was right but he could not say
how he knew I smelled that in food is
that like melange it improves flavor but
it won't change consciousness she stood
and looked down at him from her full
height mark this place well miles our
ancestral worlds are gone but here we
have recaptured part of our origins
all of the evidence seems to point to
earth being abandoned at some point by
humans due to perhaps a war or natural
disaster it is suggested that the planet
may have even been entirely destroyed
it's been gone for so long that most
humans have forgotten that it ever
existed only the most enlightened people
of the doom universe remember on earth
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]